take a look at this story from
timcast.com more than one in four
americans say it may soon be necessary
to take up arms against the us
government and actually a plurality of
of strong republicans said it
yeah it's kind of freaky
the poll was released on june 30 at the
university of chicago's chicago's
institute of politics according to their
findings 20 percent of voters including
37 percent who have guns in their homes
agree it may be necessary at some point
soon for citizens to take up arms
against the government the funny thing
is
i i bet that stat stays true for like
strong republicans forever like no
matter what because they say it all the
time
so i don't know if there's actually like
an increase in the number for all i know
it's gone down right
it felt that way watching the riots that
everyone was trying to take down the
government i mean like the mayor was
getting baptized in fire out there out
west i forget where that was like they
were all one uh in portland or something
when he was standing outside the fire
like doing oh yeah that was portland
yeah right like yeah it's you know
anybody wanted that desperately tried to
get back in the building like libyan
right
yeah they got him they got him a week a
week after i just thought it was funny
to pull this story up as like it's maga
month you see ladies and gentlemen this
is what manga month is all about all
right we got people who are losing
confidence in the government
they are scared we need to make america
great again and we need a month to do it
so this is that month every month so
does does the story and i i know i sent
this uh to you guys when i was on my way
in but does it break down in the poll
right left right party distinction any
of that kind of strong gop gop
independent democrat and strong democrat
okay now so where do so where are the
fault lines do you see do you see
independence do you see both sides right
on the extremes what would you say no
but like strong democrats 71 percent i
think say you don't need to okay but
they control the institution so they're
like don't don't don't their government
independent voters one-third of
independent voters say yes serious
one-third one-third of independent
voters and that's more than which is
more than these than the total it's more
than republicans republicans are like 28
or 30 or something and then strong gop
is the plurality 45 so
among strong gop 45 i believe it's 45
say you may have to and like 42 say you
don't have to that's the only bracket
where
the you may have to is larger
but
conservatives
believe it less than independent voters
well thomas jefferson was pretty clear
you may have to take up arms against the
corrupt government like he said that
blatantly just so you know everyone be
as part of being american you may have
to take up arms at some point if the
government becomes tyrannical he was
very clear about that well and this is
jefferson by the way and this is the
same jefferson by the way who goes over
and sees the beginnings of the french
revolution and is like yeah this is
great let's continue to do this
without you know kind of realizing which
forces exactly were being unleashed and
this is why you have these huge
differences between you know sure both
were armed uprisings against a a central
government right a monarchy but the the
american revolution's character was far
different from the the french revolution
character yeah they there was a a lot of
them to begin with it wasn't just like
robespierre and danton it was they were
starving too the americans no the french
the french were starving that the
monarch was there on their soil with
them so that was another problem they
had to face but it was the americans
were very organized they also had a lot
of outside help with being the french
which then caused the french revolution
that caused the french to go bankrupt
which was why they were starving it was
when the women came out and they were
you know hungry i think that the french
revolution was too culty it was too much
about robespierre it became about his
personality and how great he was and how
he was going to lead them well it was
like savior salvation it was it was like
a two-fold revolution right you actually
had the period where you had the left
and the right
in the uh what the parliament chamber
whatever this is where we get the the
terms yeah you actually had the radic so
there's a revolution and the radicals
and then the moderates are like yelling
at each other and then the moderates get
crushed and the ropes appear like off
with their heads and then they off with
his head you know the whole thing was
just kind of crazy first they blew his
jaw off that's the story they they he
was such a he was in order and he was
known for just talk talk talk talk talk
and then eventually they were like i've
had it they blew his jaw off they laid
him on a table for like three days to
die i'm pretty sure that's how the story
goes did they cut his head off uh after
that they might they might have
guillotined him yeah or they might just
let him bleed out let me find out
yeah robespierre turned on his buddy the
number two guy dantone who then said it
would have been better to have been a
poor farmer than a medal in the politics
of man
and that's what people uh you know it's
funny because we talk about how people
don't want to stand up and it's like
maybe they learned a lesson from the
french revolution
duck and hide the fires will rage and
burn down your home in your life but you
may yet survive
yeah you kind of want to you want to
build something that allows for the
system to change not so much be the
leader and the speaker and feel good
about yourself because everyone loves
you you know it's not yes yes i mean we
so here's the problem the united states
has
a constitution that can be amended
congress is dysfunctional the left has
been trying to use the supreme court as
their way of passing laws because they
can't actually get laws passed not just
trying doing they're doing right long
time they they blame minor minority rule
saying it's not fair that these but they
don't understand california used to be
very sparsely populated so change
happens
the problem is right now instead of
being like okay we all agree to work by
these rules they're just saying like
screw it burn it down it's not fair
you'll see more typically
like it's
i get what you're saying right and you
see this in
um actually the supreme court ruling
that just came out on the remaining
mexico policy right where kavanaugh
kavanaugh right uh caved on that but it
was sort of this this idea that
well that was a trump
era policy and even though we all
disagree with it
um
we want to keep it in place for the
integrity of the system because that's
that that was the you know the election
um biden's in now
and you know he does he have the ability
as the current president to rescind an
executive order and the rule that he
does right so you'll see what i'm trying
to say and i'm not necessarily trying to
get into that issue whether or not i
agree with that i'm just saying that was
the thinking and so you'll see that more
with conservatives saying we want to
keep the system so that everybody gets a
fair shake even if it doesn't benefit
our side whereas the left will say nah
man just burn it down yeah quite
literally you know peaceful peaceful
fires it's going to get mostly peaceful
out mostly peaceful it's going to get
most peaceful out there yeah man
you look at what's going on the roe v
wade stuff you look at uh bill maher
came out and he uh no no i'm starting
out bill maher jon stewart and he said
that uh the surprise is the f is the fox
news of supreme courts and then i'm just
i'm watching that i'm like
why because they're like these are the
rules the country was was set upon
the attitude of these people like jon
stewart
is
if enough people want it it doesn't
matter what the law is and i'm like
that's stupid because people often want
really dumb dangerous things so we have
a process by which we come to cooperate
and agree upon things and if you can't
do it well too bad
the problem is congress is dysfunctional
and so people aren't getting what they
want so they're just they prefer to burn
it down
politicians knowing that you can get
votes from really dumb people are
pandering to them and it's working which
by the way it's it's it's the amazing
thing on the roe v wade um ruling which
for 50 years stood as see that literally
was the opposite of right quote unquote
democracy right because they went to the
courts and said we don't like that these
republicans are banning this thing that
we want so we want you to make it a
federal not just law right that we do
pass through congress but a federal rule
essentially ruling that there's a right
to this that doesn't actually you know
appear anywhere in the constitution but
we're going to protect it as if it does
so that these states can't decide on
their own how they want to run their
states so it's it's this really weird
kind of situation where they banned
banning it right they banned banning
abortion that's what roe v wade
did and so overturning it doesn't allow
abortion bans it allows each state it
didn't even
it said you can't ban it in the first
trimester in the second trimester we'll
have a conversation that's correct and
the third can be banned
and
you ask these people they don't even
know what roe did or what casey did
casey changed from a viability standard
from the from from trimaster to
viability right but they don't even know
why they're protesting i was watching
this one video where this woman is being
interviewed she's like an auntie of a
person and she's like real roe v wade or
whatever and she's like i should be able
to go down and the government should pay
for my abortion and then the person's
asking is like you're in california
that's how it is you can literally do
that and she's like
everyone should and they're like yes but
everyone in california can do that
you don't live in texas
california most of the protests were in
states
where abortion will probably continue to
be right overturning row is the most
pro-choice decision because it just gave
it to the states whoever you want right
yeah most of the fighters choice yeah
right actually
right no they just want republicans to
abort their babies i got mixed feelings
about it because people say like i don't
want the government involved in in
medical procedures and then so the the
street supreme court said okay no
governments can be involved in this
medical procedure it's completely up so
then they're like no federal government
yeah no federal government
and now
now there's 50 governments that can
decide so like before there was one
government deciding the union now
there's 50. so is that better that i
don't get it the states all had laws on
on the books
they
so
rowe basically said
the the question with rowan casey is
does the baby have its own privacy
rights and the general idea was at
viability it does pre-viability it
doesn't because it's dependent
and so states were allowed to pass laws
restricting or regulating abortion and
they all did so you had 51 governments
this the federal government just said it
is not up to the con so the supreme
court said we do not have authority on
this congress will have to pass a law we
out and now one less government was
making an imposition and the 50 states
that were in some way regulating just
changed the way they were regulating so
they're all still involved
plus it's like it even goes down to the
county and state level city level too
like it's not just one government it's
thousands of governments regulating all
this stuff i've definitely got abortion
fatigue at this point the conversation
has gone on like maybe because we're on
a talk show and it comes up almost every
day but it's it's it's like
it's because
in my opinion the democrats are using it
for a very serious wedge issue they're
protesting
i don't understand what they're
protesting and and to your point ian the
fatigue
what do they want what are they asking
for california doesn't need anything
from texas new york doesn't need
anything from oklahoma
the people who live in those places for
the most part voted for these policies
and these politicians
is it that the majority of new york is
is looking out for the eight percent of
oklahoma that is concerned about this it
looks like two separate realities are at
war and they're def like because it
comes down to just one reality thinks
it's a life and the other doesn't and
like they're warring over the definition
of life or they think it is a life and
they're willing to kill it or yeah or
just i don't know man human sacrifice i
think i think you're sort of right but i
don't think the left has any real
cohesive standard by what they're
talking about yeah because
look some woman today she posted how is
it that abortion got banned as i saw
that meme on facebook how is it these
abortion abort abortion got banned
before an assault rifle
and so i just responded with assault
rifles are banned under the hughes
amendment 1984 i believe 1984. and um
you can get them the grandfather den
you're referring to standard
semi-automatic rifles and she's
responded with i'm referring to anything
that can kill a kid and leave them like
a bloody mess and i'm like okay well
that's all guns
no anything that can kill a kid right it
could be a brick right so if you've got
kids believe me like that's that crowbar
as a parent you are constantly in a
state of just when you're around your
kid you're not all right this can do
this this can do that they could fall
they could do this thing they could
they're they could turn any door they
can literally turn anything in their
home into that yeah
my i'm just use act as 86 is that right
is it a firearm owner's protection act
okay right so i was wrong
but my point is just like
if if you post something incorrect
and i say i understand what you're what
you're saying let me give you the proper
frame and you say i don't care i'm like
okay i get it you don't care like you're
literally arguing nothing
fine
then what's the point of a conversation
with someone who's arguing nothing i
don't do it i won't do it but this is
this is the this is the the rule
importance it is the exception on the
right is the rule on the left
and it's the exception on the right and
the rule on the line what is the
exception
that on the right you will encounter
periodically individuals who don't
actually argue for something they're
tribalist but it's the exception the old
the the actual ultra maga like fringe
trump diehards who believe crazy things
like come march 3rd donald trump will be
it's like okay there's not very many of
them they're not prominent in media
there's there there are some politicians
that that have pushed closer to the
fringe of that but the mainstream
conversation defined as the right for
the most part is like extremely
argumentative extremely nuanced like
look at the show we did on the roe v way
over roe v wade over turn day with with
sheamus and austin peterson and will
chamberlain we all disagree i was
listening to that show live and that was
fantastic that was a fantastic episode
but this is the quote unquote right and
it's like it's funny when people on
twitter are like tim's right right wing
and i'm just like i i lean i'm center
left on like a lot of public policy
issues i'm just libertarian
if that's the case then what we call the
left with nancy pelosi democrats they're
not arguing for anything they're not
arguing anything it is
the rule
on the left they will not give you an
argument it's the exception some of them
will
on the right it is the rule you will get
the argument it's the exception
sometimes it's tribalism it's kind of
like emotions versus logic i think a lot
of people that would consider themselves
leftists are driven by their emotional
standards but i think i think there's
another angle to it as well that that
gets into the word rule itself but it
like in in the other sense of the word
rule as power right and so i think that
for 50 years roe v wade stood as a
sacred cow for the left for a very long
time it was one of the most powerful
things that they think of it right they
were able to impose by sheer force of
will right this is the this was the
culmination of the radical 60s the
sexual revolution obviously that they
were allowed to put past this not just
in their own states they willed an
actual amendment to the constitution
into being through the courts without
actually having to go through the
constitutional process itself and
it stood the test of time for 50 years
and so i think that they realize
inherently um and even you know even the
folks like pelosi and hillary who are
around at that time they realize that
that level of power that they've had is
starting to slip away adrian curry
chatted tim is super left with sprinkles
of writing that proves it that that
that's proven yeah but are they rainbow
sprinkles sprinkles yeah
oh my oh no this is the funny thing this
one's
people were commenting like tim poole is
far right this proves it mug a month and
all that it's like
it's it's very clearly meant to be just
a silly fun thing to do that's not you
can't have fun you can't have fun how
dare you say that now in the show but
afterwards the ritual will commence
right the ropes come with the mugger
yeah it's called the fourth of july yeah
right
it's just it's yeah we're gonna grill
things up fireworks no i think i think
it's gonna blow stuff up for i think
civic is a holiday i 100 i think civic
rituals are important i think a i think
a functioning society a cohesive society
has civic rituals and you know fourth of
july obviously is one of the largest
ones but it's it's so you know even even
the more you know basic ones like you
know standing up for the national anthem
at a baseball game or there's there's a
drive-in movie theater i take my kids
too and they play the national anthem
and they say hey can everyone just get
out of your car and like they don't say
it but it's like shut up for like it's a
minute right but you stand up and you do
that and it is a natural it is a
national ritual what should happen is
that at every sporting event a large
glass holographic screen comes up with
hulk hogan playing the electric guitar
with the american flag behind him and
then fireworks start launching like
crazy agreed while we all sing the
national language we all ride eagles
into the sunset that's right thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there